i'm here with laura dern and uh i got to
talk about
jurassic park because i have a question
for you cool you were in this movie
which uh one of the most successful
movies of all time
it grossed over 80 gillion dollars yeah
gillian was right yeah
was that the actual figure 80 good and i
was just curious uh you know sometimes
they talk about
there'll be a sequel or something like
that are you going to be in the sequel
do you know no i'm not they're
actually shooting it now and uh it's
based on the lost world which is the
sequel to the book michael crichton
wrote
and pretty much it's a new cast except
jeff goldblum is
back in the in the sequel so he gets to
be back in there and ask for the big
money can't you just try and worm your
way back into that movie at all because
the money must be huge
well he had a dinosaur costume in the
background
that's what i wanted to do actually my
favorite thing about it actually stephen
always got to play the dinosaurs because
there was nothing there when we were
acting out steven spielberg yeah so
steven spielberg would have a megaphone
and when the dinosaur was supposed to
appear in front of us we would hear
steven spielberg's just going but he was
very good at it i would just be laughing
the whole time
i would be terrible at that uh now you
were i talked a little about earlier in
your career you were quite a good
student in high school weren't you
yes very good student and it meant a
great deal to me to go to university
which i did you went to ucla yes and did
you enjoy how long were you there for
two days really was a fulfilling
experience for you
no i got a movie and that's really what
i wanted to do is continue acting so i
left and then i came back and went to
usc
and got blue velvet actually and then
left again after a semester
so getting these really great movies
kept interfering with your studies yeah
that's terribly tragic yeah so then what
happened did you ever go back
to school actually this last semester i
re-enrolled in
university you went back now yes and in
fact right
basically right now in los angeles i
should be taking my final but i'm on the
conan o'brien show
that's not gonna be fun that's not gonna
carry a lot of weight
that's not gonna carry any weight with
the professor well no he's a big fan
actually
good all right then yeah hey there let
her go easy
yeah so uh you grew up uh you grew up
both your parents
were in show business you grew up kind
of fast you grew up uh you were working
kind of early weren't you and
as an actress yeah i i started acting
when i was 11 and in fact when i was 11
uh was at a hollywood party you know how
those are they actually have i've never
been invited to a hollywood pool really
no i don't get it andy and i stand
outside a lot go come on
we won't break nothing well you know how
it is when you're 11 in hollywood they
have you know
at a pre-adolescent hollywood parties
and we all hang around and
so kids like 11 year olds oh really i
just picture the kids with shades and
stuff
saying i'm in therapy that's much better
yeah okay but uh no i
kind of went up to an agent who was uh
representing a friend of my mom's and
said you know i'd love to audition for
you
i want to be an actor when you're 11.
that takes chutzpah well i have
footsteps to use a term for my people
yes
yes absolutely so uh yeah and then i
started did my first movie at 11 and
have
kept going i love it that's amazing
though and your and your parents were
like encouraging about that no my mom
didn't want it and my dad sort of
reserved judgment until he saw that i
was
extremely passionate and then both of
them have been really supportive that's
so interesting because that people in
show business
don't want their kids in it like someday
when i have kids i don't want them to be
in show business
exactly i want them to be roofers you
know we're going to be up on a roof
nailing tar down
absolutely so that i don't have to pay
for roofing
that's pretty much why i'm dangerously
insane that's my problem